i mean everything's great nothing's
changed things have quickly come to an
end for this bachelor couple e.t can
confirm nick vial and fiance vanessa
grimaldi have officially called off
their engagement just five months after
viewers watched their fairy tale
proposal play out on screen
you don't want to fight it anymore
[Music]
because i do love you
i'm in love with you
the couple shared in a joint statement
to et quote we gave this relationship
our all we're both pretty busy but we
make time for each other at the end of
the day so that's what counts the pair
added we will continue to be there for
each other no matter what it's tough
before the split news things seemed
promising for the pair of course there's
going to be a wedding but again right
now we're just not focused on that
bachelor world's different and so we're
just focused on our relationship and
everything will come in due time but a
source tells e.t things were always
doomed for nick and vanessa quote
vanessa's not really into the whole fame
thing she's had some fun with it but
that's not what she's about ultimately
they want different things our source
adds that a big sticking point was where
to live nick wanted to be in la while
vanessa wanted to stick close to her
family in canada i'm gonna be heading
back to montreal for a little bit to
visit friends and family i'll be heading
there with her i have to go back and
forth a couple times with some other
obligations but i'll be going to
montreal
[Music]